here with me now I'm pleased to say is
Jose Manuel sign up a representative of
the Koji people his translator falcus
was the filmmaker Professor Alan Herrera
who's been documenting the Koji for more
than 30 years gentlemen welcome thank
you very much all for coming here as
Emmanuel thank you very much for coming
as well first of all can you just talk
to us a little bit about the project
s
foreign
[Music]
my people have sent me here to share our
knowledge about protecting Mother Earth
because every day we are harming the sea
the land the animals the plants the air
and so we look forward to working with
you in order to protect Mother Earth
and we count on your support to do this
and Professor bring you in what kind of
ideas do you think you can bring to us
here about how to protect the Earth
foreign
see you now we wishes
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we always work with the
knowledge that we receive from Mother
Earth which we teach our children since
they are small
and this knowledge is about caring for
all elements of nature the mountains the
sea the rivers
um it is an advice that's how we call it
and we are here to share that and
especially the importance of particular
sites in nature and Professor you have
worked with the kogi for for 30 years
yes that's right and what have you
learned in that well I can amplify a
little bit on that because what he the
way they work is that they perceive
nature as being intensely interconnected
by threads that connect different
elements in the world
and they think we don't perceive these
threads and we don't know about them and
we break them without knowing what the
hell we're doing
um whereas they will want to show how
these threads connect different elements
in their own territory and that by
working with the thread rather than with
a specific location
You Can Make nature flourish much more
satisfactorily and more successfully
that if we work simply with planting a
thing in a place without relating it to
what's around it in the form of
understanding they have
it will ultimately fail and they think
that's one of the reasons that we are
failing to look after the Earth is
because we don't understand how it
functions as a living entity because
they see the Earth as a living being and
they're working with it as though it was
a body and basically their agricultural
work is also a medical work they care
for the Earth as a living entity so
we've basically got a fundamental lack
of understanding that's their whole
point and that's why when I first met
them they said to me you need our help
and I thought I've heard indigenous
people say we need your help I've never
heard them say you need our help I want
to hear more of that voice and we need
to hear that voice but it's taken a long
time to get to the point where they have
the courage
to actually show us what they mean and
it's been 30 years getting to the point
where they dare because we are so
frightening to them because we're the
Destroyers of that culture
and the the code you have lessons for
all of us would you ask Jose Manuel
about his Ambitions for cop 27 and also
perhaps it's topical and this is a new
show uh Lula has just been re-elected as
president of Brazil a man who says he
now wants to protect the the Amazon
rainforest what says Emmanuel's feeling
about that okay
amazonas
[Music]
as
foreign
foreign
okay so he's saying that the elders in
his community they also talk about the
warming that's taking place
they have additional ways of explaining
why this is happening
for them it's mostly a matter of the
damage we do down here to the land
itself and its ecosystems to to the
mother the Earth is the mother the
mother and when we do that when we
weaken the forces down here the sun
grows stronger or becomes hotter
um and so in that sense he approves of
Lula's intention to protect the Amazon
because that will contribute a lot to
ease the warming okay thank you uh thank
you very much we've had loads of time
but just tell us quickly where can we
learn a little bit more about the
project the work that's going on
the website Tyrone trust
t-a-i-r-o-n-a trust
dot org
um you can keep up to date with the
whole thing there okay Professor hello
thank you very much Paul thank you very
much thank you very much thank you very
much as well and all the better luck and
all your work thank you gentlemen thank
you